green arrow stranded is a middle-grade  graphic novel and it's the story of a  young ollie queen who's returning from a  trip with his father and at the  beginning of the story they're seeing  things very differently and when their  plane goes down on an abandoned island  ali is forced to become the young man  that he eventually will become as the  adult green hero he  has to do things he never thought he'd  have to do before start a fire build a  bow build arrows it's an exciting  adventure story it's also a father-son  story it's a story about coming of age  under very difficult circumstances  belle's art is just phenomenal it's  evocative and beautiful expressive the  lesson i think someone can take away  from this is that you can do things that  perhaps you never thought you could do  and i think that's the lesson here keep  trying keep fighting and i think you can  do amazing things in your life  [Music]  you